What's up with the Muslim are you like
Sunni Shia?
Are you Sunni? Well I want you to Sunni
be mine. If that was my sister or my
daughter whatever it was, my my right
fist would soon be yours.
I want to invite you to add something
[music] powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah
list. We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn wudu, how
to pray, how to recite Surah Al-Fatiha,
every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud, Tarawih. Every prayer
for the rest of their lives,
>> you share in the rewards. When they
[music] teach their children, and their
children's children,
the reward continues for you. For just
100 pounds, you can help teach 20 to 60
people like me learn salah. Donate today
and earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuhu brothers and sisters in the
faith. We are here in Mecca
alhamdulillah with the champion himself,
which is
uh myself. I'm joking.
>> [laughter]
>> As-salamu alaykum.
>> kind of the the the man with the the man
with the plan, if he can, nobody can.
How do you find him? Alhamdulillah. How
experience? Bro, we're in one of the
best cities in the entire world. It's a
true blessing. Okay, so brothers and
sisters, before the video starts, I
would like you guys to get a go to link
and get to your Quran Leaf, the purple
Quran or the Quran Leaf. It's my Quran
Leaf, the purple Quran inshallah. Use
this card called Salah Pro. It's 15
pounds you can get it for 10 pounds
inshallah. It's beautiful and amazing.
Give it to your Eid gift, new Muslims,
or even reverts or your neighbors that
are not Muslim. It breaks that barrier.
It's like it's Quran, it's holy, I can't
touch it. The purple Quran, read it
inshallah, simple English text
inshallah, and it is amazing, brilliant
quality. Check the link. But let's go to
somewhere there is a bit of fitna
happening, uh Kanyan. So, what is Suhoor
Fest? I have no idea about You told me
about it today. What is Suhoor Fest? So,
Suhoor I need to know. I've not been to
Suhoor Fest. No, I You were you were the
boss. No, I have not been to Suhoor
Fest, okay? Also commonly known as Fitna
Fest, but a disclaimer for the audience.
Listen to the entire video, stick around
at the end. Don't take us out of
context. We're going to cover all the
aspects cuz I know there's arguments on
it's the most haram thing ever.
Everyone's going to hell and then other
people are like, "No."
So, Sahoor Fest, in America, it's this
big gathering where from like 2:00 a.m.
to 5:00 a.m. all the youth pretty much
go and have Sahoor. Now, the reason why
people have been not liking it is cuz
there's a lot of free mixing.
Maybe people are beautifying themselves
when they shouldn't. Maybe men are
acting not
>> Which is which which is which which is
true. Oh yeah, that is what makes me
sick. Yeah, they're not only just
emasculated but also for example doing
haram stuff like going to a woman. It's
this fitna there but let's watch some
videos so that can give us a context.
So, let's start off with There was a
fight. We should watch that.
Let's Let's start with the fight. This
is unbelievable in in in Ramadan. I
stopped Yeah, subhanallah. This this is
a hit to the prophet said, "You should
not ever strike a face. Strike someone's
face." Here's a Oh god.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Well, that was not a good start, isn't
it? I saw someone put like a little
nasheed there, subhanallah. So,
we don't know what happened etc. but
irrelevant. Subhanallah,
if you're going there, subhanallah, at
least make it a place where it's an
ibadah or gets Well, you get closer to
Allah, subhanallah. Obviously, we know
there's a lot of problematic things
there but a fight?
That's that's that's to me that's like,
"Whoa." Like, you know, I don't I don't
know if that really happens with these
places but that to me is unacceptable.
Muslims fighting each other, striking
each other, you know, it's it's it's not
it's it's it's sad to see. It's sad to
see. Uh but I think that's maybe the
least of our problems maybe but we've
got other issues. Let's go on to the
next one.
>> Let's go to the next video, inshallah.
You've got a hijabbi. You've got uh
sisters who are there and the verse
that's been played above above it is
saying that the hellfire is basically
Allah's quoting the hellfire saying
the hellfire like is there more to come?
So, if you think about it, he's
basically the person who's put this into
Suhoor Fest is basically saying these
people in those videos are people of the
hellfire. And in our religion, if you
have studied the book on
Tahawi, yes,
the book on Tawhid, yes, we will study
these books. Subhanallah, it clearly
tells you that nobody can ascribe anyone
to hellfire or paradise. Nobody can come
and say Ali Dawud is Dawud is going
paradise. You cannot say that. You do
not know. You will say Ali died as a
Muslim. We hope he's in Jannah.
You can't look at someone who's an evil
doer, who's doing this and that like
this guy is going Jahannam. You don't
know, you can't say that. Unless for
those who Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has
prescribed like Abu Jahl, Abu Lahab,
yes, for example, Firaun, that Allah has
specified and said these people are in
the people of hellfire. We can say
they're in hellfire, they're burning.
May Allah destroy them all.
You can't You cannot come and say this
is haram on another level. This here is
speaking on behalf of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. It is worse than what's going
on. Let me tell you something. If you
put everything that happens in Suhoor
Fest together, it will not equate to
what this person thinking, putting an
ayah of the Quran out of context,
speaking on behalf of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala like the Christians say Allah has
a son. You're telling something about
Allah that Allah does not say about. So,
this is a major sin. This is worse than
anything that could happen in Suhoor
Fest. So, whoever does this thinking
you're righteous and pious, you have
just fell into a major sin that you need
to repent for. So, this is another
extreme of these haram super radical
individuals. Subhanallah. It leads us to
another problem we have where there's so
much division in our ummah where we
cannot listen to another person with
their context. So, these people are
like, "Oh, you're all going to hell."
And everyone else is like, "Well, we
need this so much." When the reality is
Yeah. when we when we look at this, if I
was in America right now, there's a
genuine crisis where we do not have
support systems for the youth, right?
So, I think if I reverted a year ago and
it's
you know, this is is
I might end up at a Suhoor Fest because
I have no other options. Right, so we
have to first understand where these
people are coming from and then tell
them where they are wrong. Like yes,
free mixing is wrong. Yes, beautifying
yourself and going around talking to
non- mahram men, that is wrong, right?
Playing music and hanging out and
fighting each other, that is wrong. But
these people need to be advised
correctly.
>> Okay, so when you say this is very
correct correct kind of thing, you know
why? Because at the end of the day we
need to bear in mind these people who
have wisdom will see. Now, I'm not
coming and saying
it's halal. Yes, we know it's the the
the event there's haram stuff happening
there. The free mixing and also that for
example this this thing that's just
allowed as woman beautifying herself.
This is haram. Like women will come and
say oh he doesn't lower his gaze.
Okay, but that's a matter of you know,
we can say okay if you observe someone
not lowering their gaze. Okay, we
understand. But you you shouldn't be
beautifying yourself. Let's let's be
very
thing here.
Why is it that sisters are getting away
thinking that they can beautify
themselves? Look, you are actively in
sin. Let's be honest because it's not
fair when you come and say oh that
brother is not lowering his gaze. Okay,
true. But then sister, why is no one
talking about the fact that you are
beautifying yourself? Like everyone this
become normalized. Yeah, yeah. Like
everywhere you're beautifying and you're
thinking this is absolutely normal. No,
it's not. You're actively committing a
sin. That one guy who's not lowering his
gaze to one woman, yes, he should it's
his fault. He should he should lower his
gaze. However, if you are attracting
beauty, you're there. I'm not saying
it's your fault. I'm saying both sides
are to blame. So he's not lowering his
gaze but then you are giving him
something to look at. It's in his face
and which means what? That you are going
to create a sin. Imagine 2
2 and 1/2 thousand men looked at you
because you beautified yourself in such
a way that the way you dressed etc. They
should have lowered their gaze but there
was a temptation for example. You're
both a sinful. That man will get one sin
for looking at you. You are going to get
all those men that looked at looked at
you, you're going to get a sin. So
that's another issue. Number one. Number
two. We've got these
idiotic men. I call them idiotic. Let's
watch it is where subhanallah you've got
this guy who's going up to people saying
oh like he's flirting with her. So
before the clip rolls to give you some
context, I think another one of the
issues with Sahoor Fest is it's what
type of people are you attracting there,
right? You're attracting these men who
are too tired for Taraweeh prayer, but
they want to go see the women, right?
>> Exactly. So, now roll the clip. Yeah.
So, this is the clip and so, let's go to
this clip where this guy is keeps going
to everyone and doing that. This is him,
bro, if you could bro, if I could bro,
if I saw you, yeah, coming to my sister
or my daughter, this that, bro, I think
I think that's the justification.
I would Yeah, that fight If that fight
I'm good with that. Yeah, you get
knocked out, bro. With all due respect.
Look, let's watch it. Look. Excuse me?
This is a very random question, bro. Are
you Muslim? Yes. What type of Muslim are
you? Are you like Sunni or Shia?
Are you Sunni? Yeah. Well, I want you to
Sunni be mine. You're about to
I think you're very beautiful,
respectfully. I think you're very
beautiful. You think I can get your
father's number? You know, that's so
disrespectful, but I think this is
No? My my right fist would soon be yours
if he was there. If that was my sister
or my daughter, whatever, bro, soon to
be yours, my right fist would be soon to
yours. Like, that video would end with
on the floor. That's what would have
happened. Like, here you can see we do
just cut the video short don't need to
go for detail. You'll keep And this is
the same that you keep going to
different Muslim women. He's not
actually interested, right?
>> You're not interested and you're
recording yourself and I understand
you're like, oh, asking for the dad's
number. Yeah? Okay, it's it's a correct
way to go. Look, I'm not saying you
can't approach a sister in public. I'm
not saying that cuz I've done that two
times when I was going to get married.
In a respectful way. Salaam alaikum,
sister. I happen to see you. I have a
liking. Just want to know that my
interest is my my interest in you is
pertaining to marriage. I have no ill
intentions. I would like to get to know
you better. If you're interested, can I
speak to your father? To the point, to
the detail, etc. Yes, no, maybe so,
whatever it is for that matter. And this
is what I would you ask If you ask for a
number, she'll give it. If you ask for a
dad's number, she sees it as a red flag.
This is what we're dealing with today.
So, that. But, what what do you make of
him just going to the sisters like that?
So, I think number one, if he genuinely
approached a sister cuz he was
interested, how he approached it is
wrong. You shouldn't approach a sister
in a flirtatious manner. And with a
camera. But, it's different if he's
approaching cuz he's interested. He's
approaching maybe with the right
intentions but doing it wrong. But he's
doing that strictly for the views. I saw
a video, I didn't tell you about this.
Yeah. Wallahi, bro, is insane. He posted
one of this revert who clearly looked
like she was a new Muslim. And she
comments on the video online saying, "I
did not give you permission to post
this. This makes me look bad. I'm
married. I don't want this on the
internet." Guy doesn't respond. Like I
That's Bro, that's sickening. That's
That's completely wrong.
>> deal with him, bro. That's disgusting,
bro. Subhanallah. And now we're going to
go to this obviously this sister who's
um And you know some positive stuff as
well. Like the sister Subhanallah who's
um
uh you know, asking uh sisters for mahr.
And I found this really problematic as
much as the one that dooms everyone to
hellfire, the video that we saw. This is
of uh her asking, "Your mahr
requirements?" What are your mahr
requirements?
You can throw in like maybe
50K is fine. 50K is fine.
>> I worship worships the ground we walk
on. Worships the ground we walk on.
>> [laughter]
>> At this point, finding a man is just
good enough.
>> Are you for real?
>> Like finding a good man. Finding a good
man.
>> A loyal man. A loyal man.
Our requirements are both to find a good
guy who loves us, treats us well, and
who
>> Yeah. you know, like a little bit of
this, a little bit of that.
>> Okay. Okay, and what do you think as far
as the mahr goes when you do meet Mr.
Right, what would be your mahr
requirement?
>> Just that he's hustling, he's hard
working. He cares. He cares to
>> have to like ask for something. He cares
to like be a provider.
Yeah. Okay, I love that, masha Allah.
Okay. So,
I don't know what this is la la la and
things about 50K. This guy like
seriously like I'll be honest with you,
dude. It's It's your right. Like you can
ask for whatever. But it's just become
like this like a trend thing, okay?
Subhanallah, this is the reason why
there's a crisis of people not getting
married. Not only that, what she says in
the woman next to her, it's it's I don't
care if that's a joke, bro. You don't
joke on something like that. Bro, that's
That's awful, bro. Like imagine I come
and say the woman I'm going to marry, my
should worship." And to be honest with
you, if anything, if anything, the
prophet said, and this is a hadith,
yeah, for those radical nifaqis, yeah,
those radical feminist nifaqis, I call
them nifaqis, yeah. Okay, there's
hijabists, there's niqabists, and now
there's
there's nifaqis, I've made it up.
Nifaqis are these feminist, hadith
rejected, hijab rejected,
those kind of words. So, subhanallah,
the prophet said, "If I was to ask
anyone to prostrate to anybody, it would
be the wife of her husband." Context.
The amana that a man has and the
responsibility has on his shoulders for
his womanfolk, sister, mother, daughter,
you get what I'm trying to say, his
wife. The amana is so great. The prophet
said, "If he was to ask anyone to
prostrate to anyone, it would have been
vice versa." But the issue here is this,
even if a man said, "I want this woman
to worship the ground I walk on," it's
kufr. It's not a joke, bro. What do you
mean? Who are you? Subhanallah, to do
that. I understand it might be it might
be a joke, but we need to be careful
with these statements, you get what I'm
trying to say?
However, coming to the sister of the
mahr requirement, etc., again, this is
what happens when people live in
lalaland and have unrealistic
expectations. You're putting the
benchmark so high that men are like,
"You know what? Forget this, man. Forget
this." And this is why I'll be honest
with you, this is this is why we have
incel behavior, where men are like,
"Look, forget this. I'd rather go,
excuse me, masturbate, watch something
which is absolutely haram, than go and
be married to one of these women that's
going to make my life hell." I got to
say something on the mahr though. I do
think men too much get so frustrated
with the women who ask for high mahr,
and I would say, "Just literally don't
pay attention to it. Women, ask whatever
mahr you want, it's your right. And when
guys don't talk to you, that's it,
right? But for the guys, we also have to
understand that this in social media
attracts those type of people. I don't
actually think that's the majority of
like normal practicing sisters like,
"What's your mahr?" They're not going 50
racks. I don't think so. Yeah, I think I
think this is they just say it for
social media. You know what? Cuz women
have this thing among them, it's like a
girl code thing. You have to show your
mahr, 100 5 billion. That's not making
you valuable. I'll be honest with you,
to me the most valuable woman is a woman
or who has obedience to her husband, who
follows a husband's lead, who supports
him, who's good, who follows Islam. Do
you get what I'm trying to say? This one
is the prophet said a woman like that
who does her basic salah
is obedient to her husband, protects her
chastity, she can enter Jannah from any
door, bro. Bro, that enter Jannah from
any door is Abu Bakr radiya'llahu anhu.
That's the status. Subhanallah. So, this
is what it is. But today things are
mishmash, bro. Like you just think like
Subhanallah, it's it's sad. It's sad.
But on a positive note, there was a
sister who went there with her parents
and she did say that
she did say
So, she did say obviously we're going to
blur it because obviously her hair was
showing. She said, "Went to Soul Fest
with my parents, ate suhoor, and left.
Yeah, it's somehow fitnah." Okay,
alhamdulillah. It's good that you went
with your parents cuz it shows that, you
know, you're not going there for
whatever reason. Not that I'm saying for
those who didn't go with their parents.
But what I'm just saying is
alhamdulillah, there is positivity.
Let's look at the positivity in the
sense where, look, in America you need
to understand the reality there, guys. I
can come here and speak you my bubble as
a practicing person. I'm so good. Let's
be real. There are people there in
America it's not tight knit like us. So,
there are people there they need
communities. There are a lot of people
who have doubts about their religion. If
it's a festival where Muslims come
together, yes, there's an element of
fitnah. I'm not saying the festival is
haram or halal or haram.
I would say it's more haram than halal.
However, if this improved, it's a good
concept. If it can be improved and said,
"You know what? We're going to have
segregation in the sense where to the
best of The markets we can't control the
markets. Okay. However, the brothers are
going to be in one hall. We're going to
pray tarawih together." Light upon
light. Fine example. I'll give you a
fine example. Light upon light are doing
a fantastic job. Brilliant job. I don't
know if you've been to one. Mhm. I was
one with you, bro. Oh, my bro. I keep
forgetting. Bro, I'm the guy who told
the story to my brother. I was like,
"Bro, this happened." He said, "Bro, I
was there with you." I was like, "Oh,
sorry." So, Light Upon Light event, yes,
he was with us. He's May Allah bless
him. May Allah bless him. He's from the
salah project. Um
Really, really appreciate him. He's been
there from the get-go throughout the
whole journey. May Allah bless him and
accept it as a I ask Allah that he makes
it sadaqah jariyah for you, bro. I ask
that whatever support he's given us with
those mats and those instructors that
you get the reward, inshallah, cuz I
really appreciate and value a lot. May
you imagine? bless and preserve you and
guide your family to Islam cuz my dad's
not Muslim as well, so I hear that from
that as well. So, what I'm saying is
this, light upon light is fantastic.
Segregated. Sister is in the back, the
sister no wait. So, the sister is in the
back, the brother is in the front. When
you go to the markets, the markets you
can't control. Nobody can come and tell
me, "Bro, don't go don't go to the
shopping. Don't go shopping with your
You know the very strict ones that are
like, "Brother, why did you go shopping
with your wife? Yeah? Can people see
your wife? Can they
look at your wife? Can they look at your
wife? Get get that out of your head,
please. With your with your with your
haram police kind of thing. Why are you
going to the supermarkets, bro? Yeah?
Why is a a a man so asking your wife,
"What would you like to eat?" Huh? If
we're going to go down that road, let's
be honest. Light upon light is a
fantastic example of how this can be
executed in a perfect way. Mufti Menk,
Sheikh
Imam
what's Omar Omar Suleiman etc. Beautiful
reminders, heart touching, tarawih
together, suhoor iftar together,
the markets you can go and do your thing
etc. Alhamdulillah. And it is very you
won't get this stuff. Bro, this you will
never get. Bro, if in the UK bro, you go
to a sister and like brother you get
brother let me see it'll be a jilbab.
Over there we'll do tarawih, pray and
then we'll do jilbab and prayers. Yeah,
your body will be jilbab. You you will
be dead, bro. You go to a sister and
say, "Yeah, I'm interested." Brother, in
the UK dada it doesn't happen like that.
So, what I would say is if it could be
fixed and if it could be regulated in a
proper way, I think it's needed in
America and I think it should be done in
a proper way. Other than that, there's
few elements there and I'm sure there's
a lot of people go there inshallah for
the right reasons, but that's my
assessment. I'm a nobody, but yeah, what
would you say? I would have two close
closing statements. One for the people
who attend Suhoor Fest and one for the
people who are overly hating on it. I'll
start with the people who attend Suhoor
Fest.
>> Yes.
Make sure you're doing it with the right
intention, right? If you're going there
cuz you want to like hang out with the
boys and we're just going to go chill
like maybe that's not the right
intention, right? Ramadan it's about
ibadah, it's about doing things for the
sake of Allah. We should be doing things
as an act of worship, right? And Suhoor
that's part of it. You should be having
this meal, right? To prepare for your
fast, right? And we're fasting for the
sake of Allah. So, make sure you're
going for the right intention. Like if
you were going to go, go with your guy
friends, you know, and you you eat your
food, and you talk about the right
things. You don't go intermixing. You
don't go chatting with girls. You have
the right intention. Now, for the people
who are just like overly hating on
Sahoor Fest,
you need to give advice with wisdom,
right? If you sit up on your high totem
pole, "Haram, haram, haram." You think
they're ever going to change? You got to
tell them, "I love that you guys are
trying to take that step to build this
community and get there." Perfect. Like,
imagine we get things segregated, we get
rid of the music. Amazing. We're getting
so much closer, right? And think about
how much good that will actually have.
Cuz right now, everyone who's hating on
it, all you're doing is causing
division. And then everyone who's
getting mad at them, like, it's just
back and forth. There's no There's no
common ground.
Yes. I think the Muslims have a right to
be outraged. However, the way Look,
guys, because you're upset about
something, you should I've done this
before. I'll put my hands up.
I got outraged about a specific woman
calling for divorce, and then I went and
spoke about her eyelashes. Wrong.
I was angry because she called for
divorce, and I came and said, "I was
wrong. My delivery was wrong." I
admitted it, brother. I'm a human being.
I'm not I don't have an ego, like, I No.
I'm Ali Dawah. Yes, that's me.
Yes, yeah. But what I'm saying is this.
So, don't let your outrage fall into
thing where your naseeha becomes in such
a way that it pushes the person away, or
you cause more harm than good. So,
that's what the prophet Allah said in
the Quran to the prophet "If you was
harsh with them, they would have run
away from you." So, it's very important
the way we deliver. So, brothers and
sisters, and I need to bear in mind as
well, for some people, they don't care
how you deliver it, bro. They won't have
an issue with it. You can come and say,
"Sister or brother, please don't do
this." Or, "Help." Listen, this deen is
enjoining good and forbidding evil, bro.
We don't follow this nonsense of "It
doesn't befit me or this that I don't
advise sisters without due respect."
Yes? I'll be very clear. Okay? And I've
said this what I'm saying, and the
person who I'm talking about, that "Oh,
I'm a brother. I only advise brothers."
No. This deen has come to tell you Allah
said, "Let there rise a group of you."
He didn't say a group of men that advise
men and a group of women that advise
women. No. Let there rise among you a
group of people who are enjoining good
and forbidding evil. And the prophet
said, "If you do not enjoy good and
forbid evil, wallahi, even if you
prostrate, Allah will send a calamity to
you and it will not look it will not be
accepted. It's severe. So, we need to do
this what? There has to be wisdom. Who
gives you a right to dooming people to
hellfire? Who gives you a right to say
this woman is this or that? I would be
like, who the hell are you? You can come
and say this is wrong, we should go
about the right way. Goodness here, not
badness here. So, I would end on that
now, inshallah. I think that's perfect.
>> Kanim, always a pleasure.
The man with a plan. Let's go,
inshallah, brothers and sisters. And
also, we'll just quickly uh brothers and
sisters, again, use the discount code
Salah Pro to get £5 off, inshallah. This
is a beautiful ice breaker for your
non-Muslim or revert friends, whatever
it is for that matter. Salah
go to Salah Pro.
Uh the purple one, inshallah. Get it for
yourself, inshallah, brothers and
sisters, and they ship all around the
world. We'll see you guys later.
>> And it feels very textually good.
>> It does. This is the new sadaqa jariya
in town. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us in the Quran a man pleading with
Allah to send him back so he could give
sadaqa. Why sadaqa? Because he knows the
weight of sadaqa. Just £100. You can
help teach 20 to 60 people
>> to learn [music] how to perform salah,
recite Surah Fatiha, and make wudu.
Click the link and donate now.